[Music]
Royal racist saga continues P Morgan
named the so-called Royal racist on his
talk TV show last week and the palace
are said to be mulling their response to
give us her take I'm joined by Angela
Levin Angela thank you for joining us on
spectator TV pleasure um yesterday
William and Kate and the king and queen
were pictured next to each it seemed to
be very much a sort of show of unity um
what do you think the the mood in the
palace is like this past week after sort
of the revelations from endgame and the
sort of the uh racist Royals R that's
been sort of bubbling along I think each
of them would have a different feeling
about it all but what they have done is
learned this is what Harry does now he
doesn't just attack them once he just
goes on and on and on you know with
Netflix with um Opera winley the first
and then that and then moaning to
everybody who he comes to and um I feel
very strongly that he would have known
what um would be in this book and um
he's done absolutely nothing about it I
thought he would say you know he's very
keen on suing people he would say this
is an you know invasion of my privacy
and I won't have it or say I had nothing
to do th with this I'm so sorry everyone
but he hasn't done that and I think that
the royal family have to get thicker
skin and actually just get on with
things and they've got a lot to do and I
think it's well it has brought them
together because they know the pain that
each one is feeling um and they just
feel that it's their job is to be uh
part of the raw family and get on with
what they're supposed to to do but
Underneath It All it's very painful you
mentioned as well the sort of we need to
get to the bottom of how this came out I
mean there's been an ongoing sort of
controversy this week about how the
names of these of these two Royals were
put in the public domain in Omen sco's
book in a Dutch translation I mean
you've released books on the RS before I
mean can how do you how do you think
this kind of thing Could Happen well
it's it's very difficult you have to be
very careful um with the publisher uh I
mean both Queen camil I WR about came
out as biography last year and Prince
Harry came out in 2018 I let them know I
was doing it because I wanted to go on
their engagements and things like that
but um it's the publisher that actually
has to be very careful and always they
send it to the lawyer and they look and
say no you can't say this or change the
word it's too powerful um but it seems
that um scob is um people who
the Publishers did send the wrong one
onto Holland and um I don't know how
that was done I mean you've got to be
very careful and there's lots of
sections in it that are really hideous
as well as the names being mentioned
it's not just one line particularly is
unpleasant about
William which makes you think again I
mean you mentioned this before why
hasn't Harry come out stronger against
this book If he if he doesn't believe
those things I mean yes absolutely I
thought he might the fact that he hasn't
mean he's quite happy with it and I
think that is absolutely appalling and
of course Megan is also very keen on
suing anyone who breaks into her privacy
and she's done nothing fact she was
walking down the road the other day um
wearing a BRI bracelet from the king um
that was worth several thousand
smiling away as if you know I've won
this
battle that's how I interpret it some
people say that it's sort of saying oh
I'm sorry but I don't if you say you're
sorry you you say something verbally you
don't just go moving your arm where
you've got your bracelet on I I can't
understand how cruel they've been
actually because certainly for Megan
because she'd have been nobody I me the
whole thing she's now very well known
which is's now very rich because of what
has happened if she didn't like it she
could leave you don't have to try and
break the whole monarchy
down it seems a shame as well and that
before endgame publication it seemed
perhaps that Harry and his father were
approaching something a bit of a ront
you know Harry called his father on his
75th birthday they've been talks about
Christmas them seeing each other I
presume you think that none of that's on
the on the cards now well I didn't
believe it it in the first place I
thought why would he suddenly be all
cozy and nice and want to come and why
would Earth would Megan speak to King
Charles if she hates the monarchy so
much I think it was either a ploy set up
so they can be nice and then whack them
a week or so later you know there are
people who do that bring someone flowers
and then smash them up um and vindictive
in the extreme I can't see why they did
that I thought it was a very cruel
move um we should mention as well
Harry's been in the papers for another
reason this week which is that he's got
an ongoing case against the home office
about his police protection um can you
tell us a bit about that and what's
going on there yes well Harry feels that
he should have grade one
protection um that means that it would
be policemen and that means they have
guns and they also know all the sort of
intelligence that's going around in that
but it's very
expensive and it comes out of a attacks
he has that whenever he goes to
something that's Royal you know if he
comes over for a royal event that's uh
he's protected in that way if he's not
doing anything that involves the Royals
he doesn't get that level of protection
because he's now no longer a working
Royal he offered to pay with the police
but they don't want to do that because
um any head of state any head of
companies will feel they deserved it too
so we wouldn't get the police on the
street because they' be looking after uh
other people but they they've got very
good levels of other uh protection
officers who can do that for them
without having the gun and without
knowing absolutely the up to-date but
they're very experienced and they're
very good Harry doesn't think that's
good enough for him so this is why he's
taking them back again um but he also
wants it for all four of them so if you
think four sets of top grade Poli you
need three of them a day you work that
out it's very expensive and he's not
giving anything well he's taking trying
to take away a lot he's not giving
anything towards the raw family so he's
been told not but he feels that he's
been um as you usual he's the victim he
hasn't been treated so well we heard
this that he was upset that he got four
sausages and William got five when he
was a little boy so this same thing has
gone on and on and on and on he feels
that it's not fair he hasn't been
treated and it says in the his um lawyer
on his behalf has said that it shouldn't
matter where he
is so this means and I thought this was
the plan all along that he wants us the
UK to pay for wherever he is whatever
he's doing around the world and that's
really cheeky that would have an as
astronomical cost presumably for
taxpayers exactly so this is what that's
all about I think I mean so Harry's made
the argument that he's being treated
potentially unfavorably compared to
other individuals who might be targeted
in a similar way in the UK I mean do you
buy that at all I think he seems to be
implying that it's a sort of Revenge
from the British State almost for his
behavior do do you buy that it's not one
of the things he doesn't like is that
they um asked for advice from the roers
about how much he's with the Royals um
so that they knew how much he was
working with them well it's negligible
you see and he can't be up there I think
there'll be a huge rout from us who pay
cash pay tax on on if he gets that and
can go drifting around the world
attacking the mon
at any price at any time and that he's
given that sort of protection I
understand he needs protection but he
has to go down a grade or two because of
his position now I think he still feels
that he should be treated the same way
uh he was as a prince um without doing
anything about it it's having your cake
and eat it isn't it really yeah I mean I
was wondering what you think where where
do you think the sers go from here in
the sense that Harry's had spare now
they've had that Netflix show the public
possibly seem to be getting tired of all
this I mean om sco's book doesn't seem
to have sold very well this week do you
think they're going to have to take
stock at some point and think what are
we
goinging we're waiting for Megan's
Memoirs so there'll be a la load of
nastiness in that one I think that they
they can't make it work out I think
people don't want to hear endless moans
from people living in a house with 16
bathrooms and earning Millions you know
it's sort of it it doesn't work and
what's happened is nothing has happened
there's lots of things that they say
they're going to do but they doesn't
work out Megan was going to be starring
in a film but she demanded a top grade
editor no one wants to be there you know
they're difficult to work with and so um
when she was at she was at a some a Ward
and then people said to her what do you
want to do now and she said oh I want to
do something it's really exciting I want
to make people
feel now I don't know what that
means okay um and that means to me
actually there's not much going on and a
lot of people are avoiding them now and
instead of actually being positive and
maybe having a grown gr sort of
annoying period and then coming back in
and and getting together and being
positive but they're not they're moaning
all the time and do you think they were
banking as well a bit on the Americans
sort of appreciating their celebrity and
their connections with the Royals and
now perhaps the Americans are kind of
tiring them tiring of them as well well
the Americans have got very tired of
them they don't like moners either and
also they don't trust them because they
can tell that whatever they do and say
they sell it off not everything but a
lot of the things they pass on and make
some money out of it and a lot of the
aists and now don't want anything to to
do with them anymore um and also of
course the Duke of Westminster has not
invited them to their W to his wedding
in the summer and that's a very
interesting thing and he was he was um
Arch's Godfather is got his Godfather
he's William's Godfather for uh little
George um and he is the king is his
Godfather and um so he's very high up
and I think um he didn't want a a mess
or upset the royal family that's it if
people are going to choose between Harry
and Megan and William and Katherine and
the king and queen it's quite obvious
where they're going to go bran thank you
very much
[Music]
Angela